I'll never look at football the same way
again concussion so concussions a
biographical picture takes place in the
early 2000s 2002 I believe it starts out
this one NFL player while talking you
know there's no I in team 110% it's
giving his big speech and next thing you
know these NFL players start going out
of their minds and going crazy getting
dementia and dying or they're killing
themselves Will Smith is a pathologist
he starts doing autopsies on these
football players to start dying and at
first it appears everything's fine all's
right with the world B starts digging a
little deeper doing more tests and he's
like holy repeated head trauma to
the brain has severe long-lasting
effects that people just don't want and
although he has the best intentions in
the world the NFL sees this as fighting
words now it's this dude versus the NFL
now first of all when performances are
great the movie I just need to talk
about that first because Will Smith was
excellent in this movie and we all know
Will Smith is excellent but he has to do
an accent in this movie accents will
either bring you into the movie or make
you feel like that actor is doing an
accent it's just weird for that movie at
a point in this movie I totally forgot
Will Smith even had an accent in the
movie just kind of bought it as this
dude talks his way also going to talk
about Albert Brooks in this movie Albert
Brooks is probably my favorite character
in the movie he was the right amount of
supportive and the perfect amount of
smartass which is a perfect supporting
character in a movie that's pretty heavy
and these events didn't take place too
long ago so you need someone or
something to break the ice every now and
then but not compromise their role in
the movie Albert Brooks in this movie he
was great and I'm going to again tip my
hat to the gravity of the situation like
I said it's not too long ago these
events happen so to tell the movie while
the wound is fresh in some people in the
NFL they're probably still a little sour
about these events pretty ballsy I like
and it does turn on the light to this
thing that people like you and me like I
personally just take for granted i watch
the seahawks play with the seahawks are
on these guys are just wrecking their
bodies and bashing their heads together
them oh yeah all right good job
all right Marshawn Lynch you totally got
that yardage good job ooh you took one
to the face that's what happens in your
career kind of makes you take a step
back you're like these guys are wrecking
their bodies for our enjoyment yeah also
the money they get for it for sure but
any of the guys portrayed in this movie
any of the NFL players who went out of
their minds got dementia and kill
themselves or probably argue that the
money is just not worth it at that point
what I loved in this movie was this
portrayal of this one guy taking on a
corporation that is so huge they owned a
day of the week but ultimately there is
that side of it where you're like you're
ultimately watching a Wikipedia page
play out right in front I just is
something I noticed when I'm watching
these biographical pictures that aren't
it's not like you're watching Amadeus
where the only way you're going to think
to get this information is to watch it
in a movie it's not far enough back to
put it in the meet those where it's like
oh we need to tell that story that no
one told yet it's like oh yeah there's
that story I think I read a Facebook
article about some of the events in this
movie a month or two ago there is a
scenario in this movie where I was like
yeah I've heard that like someone and I
were talking about that I think last
year so the fact of the matter is
concussion was entertaining for what it
was Will Smith gives a great performance
I love Albert Brooks in this movie the
content is heavy the content is very
relevant because this thing had to be
addressed and this was obviously the guy
who was going to do it I love the
concept of one guy taking on the NFL in
this certain situation but in the end
you're just watching this situation play
out you're like alright this guy found
something and now he has dead we have to
go through the motions and then the end
of the movie will eventually hit and
I've just kind of felt like that in
biographical picture slightly it's just
a feeling they leave me with you're
watching a very well acted Wikipedia
page you will watch once you probably
should watch once especially if you're a
football fan but after that I don't know
that you're going to feel the need to
buy it on blue right I certainly don't
feel the need to buy it on blu-ray but I
did enjoy so I will say concussion is a
good time no alcohol required all right
so concussion have you seen it what did
you think about it but ever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you seen here and you
want to see more click right here to see
more